[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be diving
into further discussion
regarding the decision by warner
brothers to drop johnny depp
aka gelat grindelwald from the fantastic
beasts film franchise
first i'm going to be doing a brief
recap on exactly what happened to johnny
and next i'm going to be discussing
possible recasting options
for the role basically depp the main
antagonist of the film franchise
the man who plays the role of
grindelwald was asked to resign
by warner brothers yesterday after
resigning he left the following post on
his instagram
in light of recent events i would like
to make the following short statement
firstly i'd like to thank everybody who
has gifted me with their support and
loyalty
secondly i wish to let you know that
i've been asked to resign by warner
brothers
from my role as grindelwald in fantastic
beasts and i've respected and agreed to
that request
finally i wish to say this the surreal
judgment of the court in the uk
will not change my fight to tell the
truth and i confirm that i plan to
appeal
my resolve remains strong and i intend
to prove that the allegations against me
are false my life and career will not be
defined by this moment in time
thank you for reading sincerely johnny
depp
the news comes after the closing of a
legal battle between depp and the uk
newspaper
over libel claims that depp was abusive
to his wife the dropping of depp has
sparked quite a bit of outrage among his
fans
worldwide as many feel the claims of his
ex-wife
are unsubstantiated despite the judge's
ruling in the libel case
that he just recently lost warner
brothers also made a statement of their
own
johnny depp will leave the fantastic
beasts franchise we thank him for his
work on the film so far
fantastic beasts 3 is currently in
production and the role of gaelic
grindelwald will be rescheduled
the film will hit theaters in the summer
of 2022
despite dropping the actor that plays
their main antagonist it appears that
warner brothers have every intention of
moving forward
with the film franchise without him
filming actually began
last month on the third installment of
the franchise which we don't yet know
the name of
we've had two so far with three to come
changing an actor in the middle of a
film franchise
is never an ideal scenario and for some
it destroys the continuity of the films
entirely however i will say this the
harry potter films were massively
popular
and if you didn't know already one of
the main characters in the films was
changed
after only two appearances albus
dumbledore have you heard of him
after the original dumbledore richard
harris passed away
michael gambon replaced him and the
weirdest thing about it was that
despite playing the role very
differently many fans didn't even
notice changing an actor in the middle
of a film franchise
at least in my eyes is not the nail in
the coffin there are so many talented
and diverse
actors out there and i'm sure someone is
going to do a fantastic job
johnny depp was great as grindelwald but
unfortunately
he's gone and given the films are going
to be coming over the next
six years i'm sure we'll have ample
opportunity to get used to
whoever the new actor is with that being
said i'm going to list off a couple of
my top choices for actors
i can envision in the role these actors
are in no particular order
first up mads mikkelsen mads mikkelsen
has the perfect bad guy
face a ton of charisma and happens to be
just about the right age for the role
in my mind when i envision him in the
role it just doesn't seem like it would
be awkward or
forced i think he would slip right in
and execute it quite well
mikkelsen is also no stranger to playing
an antagonist
and achieved worldwide recognition for
playing the main antagonist
le chief in the 21st james bond film
casino royale
in 2006 however that wasn't his only
breakout performance as a villain
he also notably played cassilius in
doctor strange
hannibal lecter in nbc's tv series
hannibal
and many others next up bill skarsgard
bill skarsgard is the son of swedish
actor stellan skarsgard
and he is probably most well known for
his role as pennywise dancing clown
in the it franchise two supernatural
horror films
that came out in 2017 and 2019.
though skarsgard's antagonistic role as
it was quite unique
and while he hasn't played anyone like
grindelwald i think that he's got what
it takes
he's a talented diverse young actor and
i think that he's got the look and the
voice to play grindelwald
the only issue that comes to mind with
bill is that he is quite young
so the makeup department had to make
sure that he looked old enough
to play the part whoever plays
grindelwald should look about the same
age as jude law
who plays dumbledore next michael
fassbender
michael fassbender is a truly diverse
talented actor
i think he has the perfect look for
grindelwald and he isn't shy to playing
the bad guy
in alien vassbender plays the creepy and
calculated david
in the x-men franchise he plays a young
magneto and in 12 years a slave
he plays edwin epps a particularly
infamous and equally awful slave owner
as far as i know the world of fantasy is
relatively uncharted territory for the
actor
but if he's up for it i think that it
could be a good challenge and with his
level of screen presence
i think he'd be a good fit next nikolai
costa
waldow i hope i'm saying that right
nikolai is a danish actor
most famous for in recent years his role
as jamie lannister
in the hit tv show game of thrones he's
an incredibly diverse actor with great
screen presence
and demonstrates the ability to play
characters of dubious morality
he certainly got the look of grindelwald
at least to me
and he's about the right age his ability
in various roles to commit atrocities
while maintaining his level of charm and
charisma
is what could make him a great fit for
this role next up
joaquin phoenix i don't think that i
need to sell anyone on joaquin's acting
abilities
he is one of the greatest actors in
hollywood today and his recent role as
the joker
was amazing he fully immersed himself in
the role he became the joker
and any actor with that kind of
dedication is a good fit for grindelwald
in my eyes
joaquin has a bit of a sinister but
calculated look to him
and i think that this would fit
grindelwald's character well in the year
phoenix played the role of the
antagonist commodus in gladiator
phoenix was an amazing bad guy and i
think that if he's able to dial in
grindelwald's voice
and he could be a great fit for the role
next benedict cumberbatch
though not commonly associated with
playing the role of the antagonist
cumberbatch is a massively talented
actor with a diverse acting background
i don't really have any particular
reason for including him on this list
i just think he'd do a good job lastly
kylian murphy
killian murphy is an irish actor who i
feel has just the right look for
grindelwald
he also happens to be just about the
right age three years younger than jude
law
he's quite a diverse talented actor with
a lot of presence on screen
and i'm sure that he's more than capable
of playing the sinister
calculated grindelwald that's it for my
list of possible actors
however i did want to address one thing
colin farrell
a lot of you've been saying that he
should be the next grindelwald but
there's one huge issue with that
his character already exists
independently from grindelwald
in the first film farrell plays macusa
aura percival graves
however the ending revealed that he was
actually grindelwald
having changed his appearance through
the use of transfiguration
to assume graves identity given that
graves is already a character
i highly doubt that he'll be brought
back in that way it just wouldn't make
sense
who do you think would be a good fit for
grindelwald let me know in the comment
section
below until next time it does not do to
do our own dreams
and forget to live
[Music]
you